e
good morning welcome actually good
afternoon excuse me
um exactly exactly
um we're here to look at parts of House
Bill 2 that um the chair of Finance has
said RNA type things so uh the first
part is
the group two pension
reform which we will we have some data
here there's the oplc section which I
have copies coming um they're up
um they're being produced
upstairs and um in one section on the
it's section 10 on the board of tax and
land appeals
that there's also section
26 which is on Department of
administrative
Services it's a very small
they're both pretty tiny right those are
very tiny but they are related to our
what pages are they on do you know they
are on the house bill two document they
are on well section
10 is on page 42 and section 26 is on
page
67 and the oplc is on SE it's on page 71
yeah okay I'm getting copies of 71 on
yeah
um I could make copies of my copies if
that helps um of those those two pages
yeah it's up to you
hello um yeah that could you that would
help
because
have
yes all
right yeah those those other sections
small
so Mr Greenland you were so good enough
as to jump into this uh hunk of
words could you
us pop up and uh use the mic they've got
the fans turn turned on high around in
this
room so what I did with this and I um I
went through and made um the language in
the group two section um more digestible
and kind of was able to compare um
current language to the proposed
language and um highlighted the changes
throughout
and also listed the effective dates just
so they're all in one place okay so what
uh what's changing that's
important it looked to me as the one one
thing is that they very clearly
separated the calculations for group one
and group
two yes they made that
more defined
and
summary what Madam chair what how are
you uh since this is kind of a
discussion meeting how are you how do
you want to handle this I think anybody
who has something to contribute ought to
say something representative Leon for
example to say something thank you madam
chair um knowing that um House Bill 727
is included in the this the budget bill
I went through to compare the language
that we had and the bill is introduced
just to see if there were any changes um
there's two that actually were included
in the amendment that representative
foot brought to us but they're pretty
significant to the calculation um I just
want to highlight those I guess we can
see those on page seven of the changes
it has the for the purposes of this
calculation that section which is
removed from current law um that still
existed in the language of 727 as it was
introduced and as it went to um get the
fiscal note so I want to make sure that
we are not underfunding it um if that
was not included in the calculation for
727 and when we get to okay so so that
one says that that limits
the
average extra and special Duty over
seven years of service yes rather than
over three years of
service which is um an anti-s spiking
provision to prevent people from uh
artificially inflating their pension yes
if they're working it over seven
years that's they're probably been
working that their whole career um but
it removes that language from the bill
because because that part is deleted oh
so that is not in House Bill too that
would be potentially a very significant
financial impact and I want to make sure
that if we move forward on this we're
not underfunding this so we need to
understand the financial
cost okay um and then okay so so that's
being deleted do we want to address each
one of these one at a time or do you
want I think so that's that's a concern
so the historical context of this is the
this was put back to the language that
existed that these people were hired
under
that that's all that does it is it just
restores that back to the original
language the changes that were made to
that were done
um if if you notice the 09
date on there so there
is
um prior prior to that the retirement
system did not separate that out so they
can't even look at that data the data
doesn't exist
right the reportable data that occurred
was just whole number
data right
so
not the the intent of the legislation is
to put things back to the conditions to
which people had when they were hired so
that's what this does in essence all
right but it still requires keeping
track
of um
ah it doesn't have the exclusion for
extra and special
Duty right correct yep correct that's
how that read in Statute in RSA 100a
retroactively all right so this one this
one is is something that
that adds cost because it uh allows
essentially limited amounts of extra and
special duty pay well I don't think this
restricts the the quantity of that it
just it just changes the way they look
at it no if you're deleting this the
that
section the the the first sentence just
says average earnable compensation
during three years of
service highest three years of service
let me make sure I'm on the right page
with you I'm on page seven of
gotcha and if this the second sentence
is being deleted MH then that says that
your highest three years of service can
include as much
special special duty pay as
um
um as you can work you can still do that
you can do that right now and it would
apply to your pension yeah
no right
now
um if you're working say 10% special
Duty your whole
career if you tried to work 50% your
10% I don't know how I don't know how
you get that cuz as a if you were hired
before 200 11 you extra detail and
overtime counts towards it if you were
hired after 2011 it does not so that
there's no restriction as to the amount
work it's just the way they calculate
that that total over agreement period of
time but that is something
to limit over time or to limit
artificially padding your pension by
working extra and overtime and special
duty pay in your last year or
so I mean I mean I understand why it was
put in there but it was it's part of the
retroactive action that was taken so
that's why it's being
was yes okay represent myam um thank you
I'm just trying to understand you're
telling me that right now you can work
however much you want so it sounds like
you're saying that this language doesn't
apply but the language says that you're
limited to those last three years
looking like prior service as far as
your extra Duty and special Duty um does
that limit currently exist or is somehow
there a work around depends on when you
got hired I'm speaking specifically to
those that are hired in this section
where you deleted this cap on on uh last
three years of service extra and special
duty pay um if you look the members who
attained bested prior to 2012 mhm um
removing for the purposes of the
calculation the special Duty and the 3
years um that have to look like the
seven years prior so that you're not
working extra hours is that actually
followed or are we somehow not following
the current letter of the law We are
following the law your interpretation is
just not accurate the inclusion in
the the annual a average annual
compensation for extra and special Duty
in those three years shall not exceed
the average annual amount of
compensation for extra and special Duty
paid to the member over the member's
last seven years of service right that's
a math calculation it does not restrict
who can work and when they can work or
how much it does is how much of it
applies to your uh average final
compensation yeah that would
um correct that well that could that
could be be significant I have a
personal friend who was a fireman in San
Francisco and he told us year before he
retired that we weren't going to see him
for the next year CU he was going to be
working all the overtime and all the
weekends and all the extra shifts he
could get MH and he did he got twice as
normal more than twice as normal pay
that year and it and it all and it
bumped up his pension significantly and
that's what this is trying to stop so
what happened in 2011 is they remove the
the
um the extra and special duties been
completely removed out totally it's not
it counts for zero if you were hired
after July 1 of 11 so that's that's been
and that is followed absolutely followed
right it's just the folks that were
prior to that that was not the premise
to which they were hired under and since
this is a pension repair bill that is
part of that okay because I'm I'm
concerned that that's got
more um I mean yes it it it goes into
the calcul
and the the actuaries have fun deciding
what it is but if we take this out it
still
allows artificial pumping up of the
pension by working in the last three
years three years is a long time I mean
you could make the argument you could do
it for seven I mean it's that's why
that's why in 2011 with the with the
overhaul they took them the those jobs
if you will were removed completely out
right right there's they don't count for
anything anymore as a matter of fact
when they were depending on who you are
if you were hired after 2011 you
actually get paid more to do extra in
special Duty because they're not taking
12% out of that okay they actually get
the newer people get paid more so um but
that's been in effect for 14 years now
and and is absolutely followed this just
this is just like I said handling a
change that applied retroactively so
that okay representative BR just so that
we can set a base for this discussion
with my so last year we put together
House Bill
436 and we worked really hard on that
bill and then there was a committee a
joint committee put together to address
all the concerns that we had and my
understanding is that that culmination
of those agreements were put into this
in-house Bill two this house bill two
but it's in-house Bill 2 now get us to
where we were going in House Bill 36
which was supposed to be a repair
pension
Bill if you're asking me if the language
is exact it's
95% exact y it's very very close it's
not it's not quite as the same um
different
Governor you know different AB different
political
abilities here with that but it's it's
virtually the same in its
premise
okay follow so to my understanding that
we're doing we're basically reviewing
House Bill 2 which is going to be
discussed in division one just because
we are the Edna as a committee we would
have heard the bill had it been part of
had it been
um if it hadn't been in if it hadn't
been put in House Bill too we'd be
hearing this bill and I believe the bill
that representative foot put in that we
retained oh House Bill 57 something
727 is being retained by us because it's
essentially
this right and we just want to see what
comes out of the sausage machine at the
end of the budget 727 does contain a
typo bys that will be brought up shortly
all right represent and this is one of
the differences between 727 as
introduced I know that we had that bill
and retained it but because we're the
policy committee I want to make
absolutely sure that we know what was
presented to us and discussed and what
is different and and this sentence was
not deleted in the bill that was
presented to us the one that had the
fiscal note it was in the amendment so
that was changed in the amendment and
the other typo that we're going to bring
up as well um was in the amendment but
not in the fiscal note and I'm just
highly concerned that if we fix it but
don't fund it properly we're still going
to be behind the eightball and that's
the last thing I want to have happen
because if we're the policy committee
and we're supposed to be speaking about
this and we let and we don't let them
know that the policy is different than
that that had the fiscal note we're
going to be setting the finance
committee up to fail and that wouldn't
be fair did we get a hard fiscal note on
727 we got an
explanation from we didn't get a I don't
think we have fiscal note do you think
so okay I'm going to step out somewhere
there is a fiscal note I believe that
division one has it and it's something
like 25 it's 25 27 million well that the
bill appropriates 27 million but what
the gentleman from the retirement system
said was somewhere in the 23
range but he had I spoke with him um at
least well let me see it must have been
a week and a half ago and he had just
sent the information to the LBA so they
have the information for the fiscal
note based on hb2 no no based on
727 so we should probably call we could
probably get I can't imagine they
haven't finished it by now no they they
haven't done much of anything on this uh
the fiscal note for
727 is a
revised what about the it's from uh
February 26 so it was
just yes a week after a week ago so and
it is
for um it's 27 million for each of three
um so
uh appropriated in the bill the language
of the bill there that's what the fiscal
note says if the appropriation and the
fiscal note are exact then the person
who came up with that number in 727
should be given a round of applause for
being the first one to get it right
exactly right like ever well they claim
the nhrs
actuary um would be adjusting
there's if I might add when I spoke to
Mr Kavanaugh after he had submitted the
information to the LBA he did confirm 27
million to me so that does make sense
right and because of the 27 million
funding it's uh the net cost is a
decrease for police and flat for
fire because of the money that was
system but that's the if you look at the
analysis the pension system assumes the
annual 275 appropriation so they're
basing it off
of off of
that well their analysis assumes it's
coming that much is coming in right so
they're they're looking at the Delta
which is uh no change for employees a
decrease that wouldn't be changing 3%
for police decrease and 0.003% increase
for fire and which is a couple hundred
28 for the state oh yeah and a decrease
for this for the localities of 270,000
so it's a much smaller number than 27
million because it's actually a
employer um but I do want to note that
fiscal note is based off of the copy
that had the typos so we'll need to make
sure that we know what the actual cost
is um
yes right
okay
citech beyond the scope of this but I
think it's worth to mention people could
buy time couldn't they yes well we're
going to be hearing what that window was
closed 14 years ago no no no no I know
there's another window there's another
provision for buying time I look I know
two people in Salem that have okay only
two way you can do it you can be in the
PE score and buy time or you can buy
military time I'm I'm telling you what
happened Steve I'm telling you what
happened and my question is they pay
they paid big money to buy time look I
don't know the provision I'm telling you
it's a fact okay can tell me about the
pre anything you like I'm telling you
two people I know of my the concern that
I have is some of those people who have
done this and we can pull hair about you
know exactly what provision it was are
going to be coming back and saying hey I
paid off my student loan early how come
forgiveness doesn't do me any good will
they want some of their money back and
they have a claim if this is restored in
my view but that's beyond the scope of
this but don't be surprised if you hear
that complaint the the conditions all I
the conditions for purchase time that I
remember was at 2 and a
half% I do remember that part of it so
if you were were in that tiered
section it all purchase time was at the
same rate
um but
that yeah that's uh I mean I I'm not
sure what type of argument they would
make with that but it didn't buy you
time another day like it didn't move
your calendar date
it all right well I think yeah it's
beond this is the kind of stuff that we
clearly have to iron out so that we have
one story that that fits all the facts
if we can get get that to happen and and
and we've agreed that that's what it is
and so forth so we don't go into this
with the with the rest of the legisl
because so um it won't go well if we're
if we don't have it all ired up all
right so
this this limitation on how
much compensation for extra special Duty
into into the retirement calculation is
being in House Bill 2 it takes it out of
uh out of the law and it would affect
only
those group
a yeah anybody hired after July 1 of 11
like I said they it doesn't even no no
no it it's vested status prior to 2012 I
ERS and it's and it's current and in
current law there's a limit on how much
um extra Duty and special Duty they can
work that applies toward their
pension and I'm curious how many of um
of that group is still working and is in
that window of years where they would
have the potential to do this and do the
rational thing which is to take
advantage of increasing their extra and
special duty pay if they're able to get
more retirement pay because that's
rational yeah yeah that number um was in
a chart that we got because keep in mind
that the the the the chart that was
given out years ago um can only go down
it can't go up yeah well there that that
was uh 13 years ago so there's people
who would at this point have at least 23
years of service okay so yeah so the
chart that was given to us
um this is
probably I screenshotted this in
2023 and that group
was at the time 344 fire and 516 police
but that's where the majority of the
retirements have come from since then so
that number is got to be pretty small
now I mean that
was that was a couple years
ago so that was
800ish total and we've had at least 1300
retire it's at least since
then yeah several hundred so that that
is going to suck up the vast majority of
that 800 ex yeah except that of course
those people still working at um
with with with that much service are
undoubtedly the the high paid people and
uh yeah typically um your Chief level
officers are not hourly folks so extra
and special duty is not in their
Universe they don't work
those ah okay well that's uh fine I
still think I want to to flag it as I'm
not quite sure we've got that funded we
don't unless somebody objects I think
that's just a concern that we want the
actuaries to look at to see if that will
make a difference it's I don't think
we're objecting to taking it out it just
it's a concern for
finance
okay okay and the other issue that you
saw um yes the other one is on page 13
of the packet that was prepared um it
had in the current law it talks about
the lower percentage for and then um
after the 15 years it's um a higher
percentage um after 15 years of
creditable service it's
2.5% so that act after 15 years was not
included in the original text of 727 so
it was not included in the fiscal note
for that um that may actually have a
much more significant impact on the
fiscal note um and because it the
language of 727 had it limited at that
2.1 through those different numbers
throughout the bill I want to make sure
that we are not underfunding this and
that this is included in the fiscal no
as well um because that has the
potential to be a pretty significant
difference in cost and we don't want to
fix things without actually fixing the
money so I just want clarification so
pres Leon are you saying that on page
13 where it says the annuity multiplier
applied to cred credible service Beyond
15 years of credible service shall be
2.5% and in 727 it says
2.1 um I'm saying that in the draft of
727 yeah it dropped that um after 15
years of creditable service that part
was removed from the bill and so that
has a pretty significant impact so when
the drafters at OS drafted it they
didn't use current law oh I cuz that had
passed last session that's what I
thought right so this would already be
there this was this this in House Bill 2
is not a change it's current law it's is
current law but but she's right if they
if they didn't do the actuary with that
in there then that that would make the
actuary incorrect maybe that's why the
actuary is different than what you think
it is so we should defin yeah I agree
except I think it's different based on
what his verbal discussion was with us
okay at the time so we so we think that
the proposed change is what's actually
in current
law okay but we want to make sure it's
included in the in the fiscal note or
financial okay
that's you have and having had this
discussion if this issue comes up which
it's very likely to do then we will know
exactly what we've done and why we did
it yeah and that it's right and then we
don't have to go through it in front of
the whole
body in your Himel on page 40 with the
current law just it's on page 40 so it's
on okay the current law is on page 40
yep just if you're referencing
if okay so so this should this is not
actually not a change although although
if we think about this though if h i it
would have to see how they ran that then
because that was
funded that change was funded two years
ago completely funded so if if they run
that
actuary right so with this one we will
we'll have to explain it that this is it
should already be funded it's not a
change corre but make sure you're not
double counting yes and my big concern
with it is because at the rates in 727
as it was introduced it actually would
have led to a lower amount for them so I
recognize that it was already funded but
this may have found money because it
didn't have those additional 15 years of
creditable service I just want to make
sure that um that the numbers are
correct because this the language in 727
that they were looking at for the cost
didn't include anything about the the
the remaining the years after 15 years
of credible service and that would be at
a higher percentage rate I I wish the
retirement system guy was here to ask
that question
because they're they run off of this so
I'm I'm talking about the language of
the law that we had that would be
different that but if the actuaries are
doing it I I'd like to see that we don't
know if they caught that or not that's
all yes we will just flag it as a
question U because it it looks like the
people doing writing House Bill two
weren't entirely sure what the current
law was no the people that wrote House
Bill 2 knew what the current law was
that's why it's correct 727 ol left
screwed that up
okay anyone else have an issue that uh
discuss so I just have a question for so
the one the issue that we just discussed
was the second issue with okay that's
well we have a second uh so does
everybody who needs to know know that CJ
Gerard died unexpectedly this weekend
and there's going to be a
his casket is going to be transported
this afternoon from the state house so
anybody who was influenced who was
that that's from Senate president's
you and specifically it says at 4:00
people are meeting in front of the arch
State House arch in order to honor him
for the those who are here just I didn't
you I can interrupt leave
at that's
fine by the way it's not often you get
out if you put I
exactly all right
so and then the the rest of it is
2034 which at which time I hope none of
us are sitting
here well maybe representative log might
be
okay so let's represent sellers just
okay
yeah and it has an explicit definition
of vested which I think
is important because it's been assumed
while
[Music]
um it's also that definition of vested
is for 10 years this also has a a
um a restriction that calculations of
earnable compensation and average final
compensation shall not be reduced after
3 years of service I don't know how
you'd ever enforce that because most
people will observed
retire um what that means is that the
legislature is restricted from making
changes after three years to those two
sections so in in the sense of a like as
Maine and Vermont do it with a five-year
vesting right that
locks that in at 5 years in Maine well
rhod Island Vermont and Maine what this
does is it kind of splits the baby if
you will because at in those States at
fiveyear vesting you're entitled to a
benefit yeah here this says no you're
going to still have to do the 10 years
like we've always
presumed but at three years the
legislature can't start hacking it back
so it's kind of a you get a little there
but you still got to do the 10 year so
this this in and of itself has zero
fiscal impact because it presumes the
current yeah the current way we are
operate but
it it's an attempt to restrict future
legislators and that's always a risky
business so I'll just flag it that
that's I mean every every program in the
country that has some sort of the word
vested and it restricts at some point
right so you you could easily say that's
at 10 years if if we're going to make an
argument about vesting at 10 years then
we'll am I'll amend this we'll get this
amended to have 5-year
vesting I mean that's and it will throw
a huge financial cost on top of it this
just this gives it kind of the split
here where there's no Financial
allocation that's tied to it at 10 years
because we presume that but to give 10
years of your life in
return okay I I think that's another one
we just want to flag it to finance and
say um it restricts the legislature from
screwing around with how with those
calculations which in general is a good
thing and also keep in mind that was
also in 436
verbatim that's not a that's not a
change a current change that was that
was in
436 uh and it and what and it and what
happened with it it with 436 yeah house
Bo 436 passed with a veto proof majority
in the house and it went over to the
Senate and the Senate decided to turn
turn it into a $50 million
Appropriations Bill to fund pension
debt ah which
failed in the house when it came back
over I remember that
right all right I I think that's
something that we ought to at least
mention to the to finance that that may
be a
concern in the sense that well if the
Senate didn't care for it uh we got a
whole different group of people running
the Senate
now all right any other concerns
points
okay we'll see okay
and Jackie you've got some uh other
sections right which do you want first
the whichever okay let's do the oplc
since I believe the oplc people are here
okay oh yes
start okay I don't think we're uh
actually talking about Canon Mountain
Tramway or the
uh or the
[Music]
uh starting off with the with the
mechanical
licensing
so this transfer
[Music]
the
building um the the plumber and plumber
electrical and fuel gas
inspectors from oplc to the Department
of Safety in the fire Marshall's
office
um I know they've been they haven't been
entirely comfortable in oplc do you want
anything to say about that y happy to
speak briefly to that so just for the
record Deana jurus executive director
oplc and with me is attorney attorney
Nicholas fry so the proposal in hb2 as
it stands presently is to move there are
currently nine positions there are five
what they we would call mechanical
inspectors so that includes Plumbing gas
Fitters um and heating
installers um that and then the four
electrical inspectors
so the those inspector positions
transitioned from the fire Marshall's
office to the oplc when the boards and
the licensing function was
transferred um I think not at the risk
of not specifically addressing other
legislation but I think this body has
heard of there's licensing and
credentialing and then there's
programming or other services that are
offered and sometimes um they're very
intermingled and uh separate that
licensing function out sometimes things
that are more programmatic get kind of
dragged along with the licensing
function and so I think the the
calculation here was this really is a
public protection they're the
inspections that they are doing are not
of specific facilities so just to give
you a sense the office does employ
specific inspectors who go and inspect
pharmacies because those are licensed by
the office as you can imagine
electricians plumbers are all over the
state and Residences and Commercial
places so there's no actual place to
inspect so it's more um it's the public
safety aspect of Code Enforcement
ensuring that they're they're doing the
work appropriately um there's a lot
connected especially with the gas
Fitters and um carbon monoxide which is
been um there's been a few higher
profile cases of that so these
inspectors are providing that Public
Safety piece and really that function
fits within the fire Marshall's mission
of you know we want electricians to be
complying with the code so that there
are not fires in buildings um and so
that function had kind of been I would
say not quite dragged over but had moved
over with the board when really the
credentialing of professionals is a
separate thing than this than the work
that they're doing and so the estimation
was the Fire Marshals is the one that in
the middle of the night see needs a
license to look at some critical issue
with the carbon monoxide The Lure office
is 8 to four and we're you know we're
moving paperwork around so that was kind
of the distinction there okay I have a a
question about it are the inspectors
paid from the plumbing gas fitter and uh
electricians license fees or are they
separately funded they're currently paid
at the oplc just has won all license
fees from boards go into one fund so
they're currently paid out of that fund
which consists exclusively of money from
licensees from fees so it is not a one
to one right so you're transferring nine
positions and I don't see that there's a
funding
transfer no okay so you're the Fire
Marshall is expected to pick up the uh
it's my understanding the governor's
office in their
proposal they there was an understanding
that it would be General funds in the
department of safety and that was that
yep I just want to make sure that's
perfectly clear yes of CC
who inspects the lifts at Canon
Mountain that's also the department of
safety yeah there's a actually a Tramway
passenger safety board over at the
department of safety
yes processed many an appointment to
that use the
rope okay it's not as far to drop all
right so that's a um
represent I'm sorry um I'm just trying
to understand what you're saying so all
right now all these inspectors have a
license and they are underneath they are
part of the oplc infrastructure right
and when you say they're paid by oplc
are we talking about the work that they
do in inspecting these facilities they
their state employees that their their
paycheck is yes yep okay I got it okay
thank you so I understand thank you yep
all right
yes follow up so they would still follow
their licensing Pro um process would
still be under OPC that is the current
proposal does not make any change to the
board or the licensing function just
those positions moving to safety to the
fire Marshall's office yep so no change
to the license got it yep thank you
okay that makes sense we just want to
make sure that we know that safety knows
to
uh have pay for nine people plus travel
yes okay and we are actively I'm sure
that you know the agencies over the
weekend received the fiscal not
worksheet request for hb2 so there
should be more robust financial
information coming um and we're
obviously included in that request and
that'll be reflected there yeah no no
we're we're fine we just want to make
sure that
it's it's open and everybody knows about
okay the same with the electrical
inspectors that is correct which is fine
okay
all right anybody have any issues with
that other than making sure the the the
inspections so you're adding a
definition for
shop which is uh probably
right all I don't what have they got
there there's
schools no actually you're not you're
not apparently licensing the school it's
changing to licensing the curriculum is
that correct on page 73 near the top
Roman uh
7 I'm sorry the page numbering is
different on the different printouts um
no doubt no doubt it's
looking it's changing from light
criteria for licensing and approval of
schools and their curriculum to criteria
curriculum which which is not at all the
same
thing it's it implies that there's no
approval of the school as a whole
because you took out I see okay
yes yes so the the as proposed this
would not include the school facility
being
inspected
but um but it also implies that you
school not criteria
for because the
and was a condition of both things if
you take the word and out no it's
not right it's not at all the same thing
well I'm happy to look at that it was
not a proposal to eliminate a license
all right that was or that I will say
that was not the intent so good is it
that's a a significant change that I yes
no that was not the intent I apologize
so so it's it's to eliminate the
facility
inspections or
actually I don't think I don't know if
you need any CH there at all if you you
criteria yes
let we will have to get back with a
recommendation to include or to not
exclude the licensing of a school
because that was not the intent okay yep
well that's uh we'll leave that ball in
your cour thank you attorney fry will be
right on
it whatever you say I hope you heard
that
I saw him he did he did he heard the
smirk
too all right so exemptions admit
standards for operation health and
safety uh represent gr thank you I'd
like to go back to the definition of
shop because I looked at the RSA 313a
colon one and we have a definition for
barber shop so I how does that
shop means Barbershop I'm trying to are
we saying then if you go back to
Barbershop is defined in section three
of
that I haven't had the chance to go back
through the rest of it but why are we
adding this
definition because there's also a
Salon I say 13 A1 yeah if you look at 13
A1 section three barbering there's
Barber Shop means bar yeah and then
later on there's a definition for
Salon which is mobile Barber Shop is
defined in Roman 11 Salon is Roman 12
right and barber shop is
three right so this just says we're
we're being we're using shop as a as a
term to apply to all of those things yes
represent and um on 3113 d19 there is
shop ler so that may be to clarify what
the meaning of shop and Shop liur is
okay as long as we're not conflicting
ourselves thank you I was trying to
understand it myself that's when I found
that part so that's where shop licensing
colon9 that was updated um July 15th of
2023 so I don't know if that was part of
the large process wait a
313 a19 oh a19 okay yes we we change
things then all 19 yes shop
lure uh to
maintain uhuh okay yeah fine so it's
shop is just shorthand we can handle I
think we can handle
that um and that defines for maintain a
salon barber shop or Mar mobile barber
shop so that's consistent with a new
definition
okay okay that could be simplified being
shop means anything at all pretty close
yeah any facility that needs to be
inspected for initial licensure would be
included in that yep okay and all right
so then there's a new Roman
14 uh what onetime certification
programs are the equivalent an AA
certificate that me or exceeds 10 hours
and is earned in barbering cosmetology
manicuring or Aesthetics for the purpose
of operating a shop or
school
so so that says that uh somewhere you've
got to be talking
about the user
certificate yes so if you again we have
different page numbers but in the
section that is amending
313-a 19
Roman
2 ah there's the section there so
the the statute as proposed contemplates
that there could be another course in
the universe that would provide the same
level of training and it the previous
section you referenced that Roman 14
would put the onus on the board to
create rules just to determine what
others may be encapsulated as to not
prescribe the only one
course would meet that qualification
okay so
that
um meets all the
requirements and there's
a for an inspection conducted on initial
lure or for an inspection conducted upon
initial licenser and the licenser has
their
I it
would there are a lot of words
there I wonder if there could be fewer
words to say the same thing in that
specifically um Roman 2B so I guess
actually representative Pearson was so
kind as to give me the copy so I am on
Page 75 in your packet there right all
right so
um so that if I read this correctly it
says that when you do an inspection upon
initial lure
which you can do it differently if the
leny has the certificate is that correct
yes so the proposal be uh in hb2 is that
a a shop owner so again shop is our
short hand for any facility owner that
falls under this
jurisdiction they have two options
everyone will have an inspection for
initial
lure and then they can choose to either
get the lifetime sanitation training
certificate there or they could choose
the current process which is that they
have an inspection upon
initial a licensure they have a routine
inspection the next year and then they
have an inspection for their renewal of
their license in which would be after 2
years so presently a
shop is getting an inspection every year
the initial the
routine renewal routine
renewal routine and so on because that
that seems a little excessive so
that I would agree with that assessment
and this this policy says maybe we don't
need it maybe the safety and sanitation
would provide some public protection and
to say that they've had the adequate
training they're certified in that way
if they can demonstrate it then the
office instead of going every year could
respond if a complaint came in against a
shop or a shop owner an inspection could
be done in response to a complaint to
verify that they're in compliance with
I'm sure that the language here says
that because this implies that there's a
different initial lure inspection if
you've got that certificate it doesn't
whatever Madam chair I'm not I'm not
really in favor of having people go in
if there's a complaint because if
there's a complaint it's already an
issue right I don't I we don't have to I
don't know what the criteria is but I
agree with the chair that this doesn't
say what you just said so that no the if
you look on the next page the Roman five
is new and it says it's the obligation
of any individual who runs a shop to
ensure the shop maintains compliance
with with rules and and failure to
maintain compliance is conduct
sufficient to support dis disciplinary
proceedings so that if there is a
complaint or there is some reason for
the board to initiate an
investigation um you can go in and
expect and do anything but where does it
say that
the um that you have multiple
inspections of a of a barber
shop I mean is that in statute or is
I don't know the answer to that I'm
I'm I'm 80% sure that would be C
incurrent rule in the PLC 400s I don't
know that the annual inspection is
currently in law if you're looking at
this it um it talks about a you get an
inspection
um it doesn't say you get an inspection
except at
it doesn't say anywhere about
inspections attorney fry is going to
pull up the current statute to see if
there's any if I may I do remember a
conversation with um some of the oplc
inspectors that we had testified before
us that if I'm not mistaken the
inspections are done every two
years but oh there are only a few
inspectors and because they are also the
same ones that are investig getting the
complaints it's a stretch that they do
it every two years okay so what it says
is sanitary if you look at Roman 313 a21
Roman 3 sanitary inspections of all
salar barber shops and schools shall be
made at least once a year so that is in
current law yep so we we really
recommend you delete that as well okay
because if you're going to do it on
initial lure and when you think there's
a need for it or you're doing an
investigation you you don't want to have
routine
inspections I got a question for you yes
I think and for you
D the annual inspections that are
occurrent in current law right that are
occurring yeah what are they finding in
those annual inspections are they pretty
much routine not a big deal are we
finding problems
like what is what is the current status
what is the current result of those
annual
inspections the the office is in a a
slight well not a slight there's an
adjustment of the procedure on the on
the half of the office about how these
inspections are completed um so we're
moving towards a model and they have
started to roll out where they're going
in for inspections and the shops have an
opportunity if deficiency are identified
to have a a deficiency correction plan
to rectify it and and then move forward
there so the there are deficiencies that
are identified I don't I could maybe get
you like a generalized report of what
they're finding but it it's generally
cleanliness these inspections are
lasting some of
them none of them are more than an hour
and that would be like quite a large
Salon with a number of people there so
they're not um
there basic sanitation I mean I I don't
want to get into details about
fingernails and Combs and hair on the
floor but that's the type of that's the
type of I won't go to a barber shop that
doesn't have hair on the floor because
it means they're not
working well if your barber shop has
hair on the floor and inspector comes
they may be written up for that so they
ought to at least a br swing a broom by
every few people but I think that what
you're trying to do you you have to
repeal uh that Clause that says they
inection yes I I agree with you all
right the intent how do we feel
about going from requiring annual
inspections to saying when necessary or
or
triggered we got a definition for when
necessary and
triggered it's in uh I don't have a copy
of that I gave it to her so I'm
oh we've got some spares here pass this
but
down it says that um it doesn't talk
about it it says that the board can take
disciplinary action against any
licy all right uh the shop owner or
manager must maintain compliance with
this
chapter
so gu
they're supposed to be doing that now I
mean all this basically if you're a shop
owner you are supposed to be keeping you
know you're supposed to be doing that so
this to me just States the obvious but
then I have a concern with I understand
that maybe once a year is a lot
considering how many but at the same
time just leaving it to when there's a
concern or when there's a problem to me
that the the import of an inspection if
I remember speaking with the inspector
was
that um it
triggers Corrections and it and most of
the corrections have to do with hygiene
and so it's important to trigger those
things before somebody actually gets an
infection right so maybe we you know we
extend it I have a concern just
eliminating it and this to me um
is Section Five where is the obligation
of the individual ual I think it's their
obligation anyway but um it should be
yes so to me that's stating the obvious
but if we need to put it in
law you know that seems I think we would
want to say that you know if if it if
any inspection finds something there
shall be a follow-up inspection I mean
that's that's what you really want is to
is to concentrate on the places that
have
problems would that well you want to
have some kind of a modality I mean
obviously we know that the owner has the
responsibility right clearly or or if
they they have somebody else who's the
manager then it's the manager's
responsibility but there's a
responsibility in law I'm sure I can't
believe it isn't uh to that cleanliness
be maintained and you want to have some
kind of a modality so if there's a
complaint or a problem that they can
address that because once a year
well you you know lots of businesses you
you see them and they're constantly
cleaning but as as Steve said uh if
there's not hair on the floor they're
not open you know because you just can't
operated but you have to clean it up on
a regular basis so that the place is
clean at the beginning of the
day so if if if the inspection routine
of this yearly thing is in rules is it
in rules yes it's also so in statute it
is in statute oh it's in statute okay
that was the a21 Roman 3 okay and that
requires an annual inspection and I
believe the point is that you want to um
do fewer than annual you and you want to
concentrate on the dirty places and I I
do think if we're um I'm sorry we're
looking at the PDF from the website of
hb2 but I think so so section
202 it's actually a repeal and reenact
of
a21 only to include Romans 1 and two and
Ro they are where's that that text so
text oh I you see so it it is a repeal
on page 75 a total rewrite M so that
okay okay at the time of initial and
initially okay this calls for
annually
um or for an
investigation unless the certificate
right the health certificate has been so
achieved would B anually be more
annually okay the lovely word by anal
yes
every two years or twice a year that's
it I think that makes sense that that we
you only do a routine you do a routine
inspection sometime in the licensing
period And if necessary do it
again if you've got um issues all
right yes thank you for noticing that
that's a repeal and replace so that so
you're doing away with it then what
we're not no we're saying that they
sanitary inspections at the time of
initial lure and by annually thereafter
gotcha unless you have a certificate
investigation now do we want to have
something to reference a frequency
change if there are violations or does
the oplc have the authority to say okay
we found a significant problem we'll be
back in 3 months we'll be back every six
months that would be in the rule that'd
be rules yeah LLC already has authority
to inspect anything upon its own
initiative perfect so we would not
necessarily even need a complaint to
respond to we don't make a habit of just
chasing people around uh but we do have
the authority if a concern arose yeah
okay and uh there's a You're repealing
The Apprentice registration
apprenticeships the section
that it says um Apprentice registration
and certificates but it actually is it's
a repeal of a section about providing a
social security number ah uh only Roman
Roman five yep so it says they shall not
be required to provide a social security
number as a prerequisite for obtaining a
certificate which is uh in a direct
conflict to RSA 310 which is requires a
social security number for any
credential from the office in federal
law okay so we that's say all right so
apprenticeship okay that that's not a
then guess it would be a big deal if it
stayed well eventually yeah
okay just for from a procedural
standpoint are we going to make comments
to division one based on this discussion
and and you will be assembling that and
doing that who's doing that okay yes
because um they've going to go be going
through it but we have um so at the
moment we got a couple of red flags and
some minor and some changes here with
the uh the inspections
okay the one other thing it might be
worth including in a note if I may is
there there is pending legislation in
the Senate to change the number of hours
required for some of these uh license
types so I I guess I would just want to
be mindful of when we're overlapping in
those dates because there is a proposal
um but we're not going to make changes
based on a Senate bill that hasn't come
over to the house yet so when you see it
I guess you could be mindful of that we
will take a look at it and make sure
that the effective dates are appropriate
thank you that's that's the easiest
think and what else and I think
the
um couple of years ago we had a bill to
allow some school some
apprenticeship for lure and that doesn't
there
okay are there do you have rules for
um petition for exemptions from the
cosmetologists we will look that up for
you presently don't have that off the
uh because at the moment it's got 1500
apprenticeship but yeah so for specific
to cosmetologists that's 313
11 right so that is an either
or okay yep and but Roman 2 has got a u
exemption anyway we'll uh when we get we
can take that back that okay okay all
right anyone else up the sitech where is
it's in the Roman it's in the definition
section it is um 13 terrific I just want
to know that it is yes a dedicated
program the purpose of teaching
cosmetology manicuring barbering or
Aesthetics okay good it's pretty broad
represent
Bailey can you turn your microphone on
so we can hear you going back to page 73
I aren't there 24s the new bolded one
and the old conditions and standards one
sorry yes aren't there two item
14s conditions and standards and then
the new B you're so
right thank you for catching that put
that in there just to see if anybody
everybody knows our rooman
numerals I I'll just mention that to
finance and I think they can be trusted
take care of it thank you I would not
attorney fry is right on it they do have
rules it's B A
r35.1 applying for an exemption okay so
that's so that if somebody comes in
with uh one couple of classes in the
school and then some apprenticeship
hours you
can yes it does appear that um they
could be updated because one of the
requirements is if they've registered as
1989 probably you don't have very many
apprentices left who did
that fair fair point
okay here I have a question
yeah I just read this on so this is
after the
um the this the section that we looked
on for the initial lure and B anual on
the next
paragraph which is section three page 75
five it talks about the board may take
disciplinary action rather than
policy oh okay right yes it is so I
think that's to give them more
flexibility yes it would it would allow
other disciplinary rather than just
revoking it that there there's other
sanctions other mechanisms under 31012
that they right but then wouldn't it say
may revoke or take disciplinary action I
would say revocation would be included
in the Slate of options of disciplinary
action you okay as long as that okay I
mean the goal is compliance right
obviously we're trying to work with them
to right so hit hitting revoke right out
of the gate I think is is like it's
better to turning it up to 11 right away
if you get what I'm saying I just want
to make sure that we have got that
flagged
right a a new section on operating a
school
okay
so a school has an
inspection on initial
lure but it doesn't necessarily
look oh no yes School you you may
inspect and sanitary inspections are
um jumping back to the disciplinary
licensing disciplinary actions I looked
and in that um the larger statute for
oplc 310 the sanctions include
revocation of a license so that just
all
right all right so we have a couple
of um comments on the pension section
mostly to make sure that Finance
understands what the current law is and
what the changes are and they've they've
properly accounted for the the
costs
um and on the rest of them the um
lure again we want to make we don't
object to relocating the inspectors we
just want to make sure everyone involved
knows what the costs
are and then
for uh
cosmetologist
um director jurius will tell us about
the licensing and approval of schools
and curriculum because I don't think
that that says what um what you want to
say
we'll get Roman
established
and
uh under on page
75 Roman
um and I I think that the second that
little B paragraph is
I'm sorry which are you talking about
the page 76 page
75 there's the about the shop um gets a
getting a shop license the board will
um meet all the requirements and the
rules and have an inspection on the
initial licenser and it doesn't and
the initial inspection is not different
if the if they've got that certificate
is it or do you tend it to
be what my understanding of that is
everybody gets an initial licensure and
if you've got that OSHA certificate
then it gives you if you don't have the
OSHA certificate then you're going to
get an inspection by annually no that I
don't think you need it here because the
the new section on sanitary inspections
which is on page
77 shall be made at the just pointing in
inspections at the time of initial Lure
certificate or when there's an where
there's an investigation that's needed
to be uh I'm sorry I must be blind I
don't see that on page 77
it's uh Roman two inspectors oh I see
all shops and
schools so why do we have that there and
then have it
again I don't see that we need it I
think we I think we don't want to do the
change on page
75 because that they meet all the
requirements in the rules and then it
and this the inspection is in the
rules I think
nicely I well I think the portion in on
page
77 it refers back to the portion on page
75 so it's incomplete if you don't ah
okay it does yes personent
a19 19- a which is on page
yes all right I think we this we need to
figure out where we call out that
certificate and um the exemption is in
so there should be a second reference in
on page 77 to to call it out for
right I have a question on the um new on
New on the operating school section is
this meant to expand or what is it
what's the what's the objective of this
I think the the idea of 19a operating a
school is to have it kind of par the
inspection and approval process to
parallel that of a shop so I think it
just brings it more into into parity to
say that to to say that the onus is
on right you know the applicant these
are things that we assumed were were
there all along and you're just putting
them into statute
yes is that right I I believe so yes I I
will double check for you and I do I do
think there are um you have a case
before you of language that was drafted
and then a few decisions were made and
adjustments were made but perhaps not by
the attorney with the most direct
knowledge of where things could fit and
so I we we could Supply some language to
try to clean it up for you in terms of
so just so we understand the the ask is
to change it to a by annual so once
within every 2 years inspection or the
OSHA certificate for every shop and
school okay or end with the re the
option of invest inspecting any shop
that the board believes needs it and
with as few words as possible in in as
few places as possible okay yes okay so
I'll I'll make sure that they know that
there's
some new words expected on this we like
we'd probably like to see it too
absolutely well we will send it to the
chairs of both committees how's that
okay we'll deal with that all right and
then there's one other section on the
there's I have a small section on the
tax and land appeals and then there's
three pages on the D Department of
administrative services so I'm passing
out the the easy one for first all right
appeals it's section 10 of the handout
which is Page 42 so it's section
ah and and what it does it changes their
appraiser to such clerical and Technical
staff as may be necessary I mean they're
position and they're also eliminating
I'm just trying to figure out what the
result of will be of
that well instead of having a specific
appraiser they'll
have
um I
mean that sounds like they need to have
at least one person who is knowledgeable
about appraising and U the value of
property
staff I agree I
think just the board hire what they need
okay
okay then the same thing with the clerk
instead of a a clerk appointed by the
necessary those of us who were here last
we remember that we went at border of
tax and land appeals in very fundamental
ways and it it had kind of been on it
running its own shop for quite a long
time without much review and there were
some deficiencies in the way they were
set up so this is an attempt I think to
clean it up and give them more leeway
but not specif yes and it looks in the
next
section they're saying that the
um their hearings instead of being in
the
I mean that's where it is it's right
there next to the Dr building very close
anyway uh to the Dr building and right
but current law says that each hearing
shall be held in the county in which the
Declaration is filed so this this says
we'll keep you guys right here in
conquer right which is probably an
improvement represent Lam and it also
allows the electronic or telephonic
means um to participate in the
compensation hearing so that allows
people to not have to travel as far
either within their County or that's
making up for not having it convenient
but having it's like the doctor doesn't
make house calls anymore you go to the
doctor the doctor doesn't come to you
and
that they're they are a very important
entity as opposed to otherwise you got
to file in Superior Court right
right all right so still have that
option but Board of tax and land appeals
is specialized in board and tax and land
appeals yeah so so the the question is
this appears to be saying do it in
conquered participate
electronically and do we think that's a
reasonable change to make I think so
yeah okay as long yeah as long as that
electronic part is there because if you
live in Coos it's two hours yeah no
okay so so that is a change but we're
right
y all right so this will save on travel
for for the board and for the
petitioners
yes exactly all right so we're we're
good with
that
and
no okay are we going to the next section
so the next section is the Department of
administrative services and it's three
pages and we had a problem collating it
so I'm going to hand you one page at a
time
oh
well we're we're all perfectly capable
of
the okay anybody can fill unfunded
positions provided they don't go over
their
budget I think
deal we're focusing on the department of
administrative Services yes yeah we I I
think uh resources is looking at the
wetlands
Council any
yeah well they it's it's under Das
anybody they raised the amount that can
be spent without
prior approval of fiscal fiscal
committee from 50,000 to
100,000 which is probably this is for
Grants and um Federal
benefits so I think that's not not $1000
for sorry $100,000 for these types of of
projects isn't really I'm not going to
worry about it okay
this is what they did with the executive
Council a couple years ago when they
went from 5,000 to 10,000 right and then
they may have moved up again ah and then
on transfers within accounting units
within their
department requires the approval of the
commissioner of administrative
100,000 all right I'm just wondering
about so in underneath Bridge House
special accounts they're established
there is hereby established in the State
Treasury the bridges House special
account
fund and it says they change it from the
funds may be comprised of the governor
is authorized to expect to accept public
funds gifts grants which shall be used
for the purpose and care of bridge
houses mhm so is that something
that let's see if that that exists
already it might right and I'm just
wondering if why are we changing it to
the governor as opposed to the funds May
is that they because typically if you're
accepting funds there has to be a ve
vehicle by which you accept those funds
there has to be a approval process this
doesn't
um this doesn't say who who is currently
authorized for Roman line it doesn't
look like there is because it says the
funds May comprise of so there's there
isn't anyone who's authorized to accept
them and I guess they're saying that the
governor the question huh
yeah I I think there's a this is deals
with the bridges house this is one
building one particular building over in
East conquer the bridges house and so it
should be it should be capitalized
should be capitalized every time it's
used in the paragraph I think because
this is not about has nothing to do with
Bridges no not at all this is all about
the Bridge's
house okay so that's
nine 4-9
section we don't have an RSA 4-9 oh wait
is ah there is in fact a 4 49- S which
account and it doesn't say who's
authorized to accept or so that's I
up it's already there okay but I guess
um you're right representative
we should capitalize Bridge's house
because that's confusing it makes it
looks like well I mean it could be
misread and but the thing is and and
since and putting the governor in charge
of it is is a wise thing instead of
putting it then you got to decide who's
going to who's going to run this thing
yeah and there's currently nobody
authorized so yeah we want somebody okay
that's fine
[Music]
governor and then on the next
paragraph it says that the anybody who
gets federal funds shall set aside the
indirect cost
portion except the the commissioner of
administrative Services May wave
I'm not really clear what they
specifically can wave if it's the entire
section 124 which has to do with federal
funds or if it's more specifically just
to the audits of federal grants because
if we're able to just change what we're
doing on federal funds based on one
person that seems like a pretty big
policy choice but if this is just around
it so we want to know how big the
12416 say it does say audit audits of
federal grants fund set aside and it's
just a a requirement under this
fund it yeah okay so we that's perfectly
normal we
um I think looking at this there has to
be some provision for a waiver because I
mean if the amount set aside is more
than you actually need to pay for
compliance cost then you don't want that
money just sitting in account yeah away
yeah if this is uh the so when you look
at the titles on the section there's
audits of federal grants it has 16 17 18
19 so if this would just mean that
subdivision and not all of 124 that's
fine I just trying to make sure I'm
parsing the language correctly because
whether or not a grant is to do gun
confiscation that's against ours or
something else that would be a different
political issue I would just be
concerned if it was a larger part but if
this is just about the Audits and that
sounds like that might be the correct
reading I'm fine with it I just rather
raise a flag that may may not mean
anything then let something go by yeah
so you're forgiven yeah they're talking
about the Audits and that all funds set
aside shall be credited to a separate
account and used only for the audit and
the LBA will do the
audit
uhuh all right so yeah I think
the if they're talking about the waiver
they may say we don't need to AIT it is
I can't believe that they say they don't
need to audit it so I'm I'm not sure
what what the point of that section is
there's a just to be
consistent uh before we were
capitalizing Bridge's house and in the
paragraph below we're capitalizing
administrative services but then we get
lower down in the paragraph after that
it's not capitalized as commissioner of
administrative services
[Music]
H well I think we can let administrative
Services capitalize or not but the
bridges house we specifically want to
capitalize it so it's not confused with
things that go over rivers could we add
the word the in front of Bridge's house
it is called the brid's well in here it
just says Bridges house but if if it was
just the bridges house it in the text I
think that would be a good
change I I see is hereby established in
the State treas Treasury the bridges
House special account fund both in the
title and in the first line of that text
oh just at the very beginning it just
says Bridges House special account I
didn't I wasn't really reading Beyond
okay but yeah that just from a I mean I
in Inc I just put it in quotes on my
paper just so I knew it wasn't didn't
have anything to do with Bridges
all right we'll we'll point that out
it's easy if you remember that that's
what we have that passes for a
Governor's
Mansion yes as a matter of fact I've
been to events there that's uh that's
there you couldn't call it a
mansion if you've ever been there it's a
very
plain
limited but no the governors basically
don't use it okay so the capital project
uh they'll report quarterly and annually
okay which is I think that's that not
anything um it does have the combined
reports go to annually instead of
quarterly but that I don't see a
particular reason to say that there's a
problem with that
yeah because they're giving uh
ah so the on the uh Support
Services
the um the Surplus distribution
section should only have a capital
reserve of 3 months
operation instead of
that I think combining that with making
it continually appropriated in on
lapsing um just helps to sort of smooth
it over time it seems reasonable to me m
okay
yeah well will the I would imagine that
the depart that the commissioner will be
there to weigh in on this
right uh yeah because I really think
that they would know better than we yeah
on
the other thing too is at three months
is this you could be in the middle of a
project well this is the uh Surplus
distribution section this I think this
is the white
Farm yeah white we on Clinton Street
yeah
um yeah Whit's Farm is
um I've been there many
times
but
that tool of money that they generate
right from the auctions and whatnot um
go depending on what their auctioning
some of that is
local um municipalities use whites farm
right for Surplus equipment as well so
um this is just to cause them to dump
that fund into the general
fund more four times a year instead of
two I mean that's well no it's um
the the the
fund is continually appropriating and
non-lps um so I think it it would have a
uh you know every time it goes above a
million dollars or $5 millionar or
whatever it is that's when it gets
sucked to the general fund okay so this
is but at current
time it says allow the accumulation of a
working capital reserve equal to the
cost of six months
operation of the distribution Surplus
distribution
section I would imagine that that
operation's fairly consistent I would
think over there they're
not you know adjusting employees and
things of that nature in a short amount
of time
it's so and Whit's Farm is a it's just
an
old just an old building is all it
I yeah I mean their expenses are pretty
consistent you know yeah think so they
won't don't need to have a whole lot of
uh
um but I have a question on this if if
well their expenses may be predictable
but what about the source of their
income is that predictable as well no
not at all so that's probably why having
a a 3mon window may be
risky well no it's the way I I think
this is is the what they figure out
three months operating income yeah and
when their bank account goes over over
that they suck it into the general fund
okay and that's just to make sure they
don't don't go too low so when you
attach the the term
date it's it means that at the end of
the budget cycle they don't empty it out
they leave it at the um the working
capital of
it so but but they don't because every
three months they're going
to right I mean that's no I think
they're going to keep if they go for a
million dollars a month to run the place
M they'll keep their Bank their account
at $3
million and whenever it goes up because
they they just sold an excavator to your
town or whatever that's when it gets
sucked
in it's not I don't think it's on a no
and and I think the word is continually
so it's continually appropriated non
lapsing it's continuously non-lps that's
how I read that so it's it's always got
the three months Reserve so they'll so
in essence they'll establish a value to
that and then when they hit the ceiling
it just then it just starts coming over
I think so yeah okay I think that's all
righty and there's a new paragraph which
ominous they can use any money they have
to pay penalties fines interests or
other costs
imposed on the state by the retirement
IRS
which well that LE that lends itself to
a lot of questions it does it sounds
like they're expecting some
yeah I would love a historical
perspective on what IRS and retirement
system finds they have paid well
especially the next sentence when you
include that right the department will
seek concurrence with the Department of
Justice I don't really
understand I mean that's so the the only
findes under the retirement system that
that an agency would do is if they
violate like the 150% rule as an example
right they would pay but there's there's
really there's other than that they have
a duty to report within a within a 180
days of retirement that sort of thing
but it's not as far as fines by the
retirement system it's there's virtually
same with the IRS I mean the uh payroll
processing ought to take care of uh that
sort of
thing so unless unless the governor is
expecting to be audited yeah represent
Howard yeah um I'm just wondering uh if
there have been any situations where
people have uh fully exhausted all of
uh for what for I just in terms of uh
this this new section just because it is
a new section I'm just wondering if
anybody has gone through uh the current
appeal process and exhausted all of
their um
I I've never heard of it yeah and I I
can't imagine that the the state
government is normally uh
um you know failing to
withhold retirement funds or federal
taxes or
whatever okay all right thank you or
even you know late
reporting I mean it's not well the very
fact that it's a brand new paragraph
yeah suggests to me that it's there for
a specific reason and that we should
find out what that reason is because it
does say you know uh any any relevant
appeal process and then down at the
bottom Das will see concurrence prior to
processing any such payment so they're
they they don't have a free hand you
have something represent yeah so 10816
is the section that involves fines
within the retirement system um there is
a $25 a day for non-comp with the data
reporting
paragraphs that are in
a16 um including data that was not
timely remitted or data that cannot be
processed at the time designated by the
board that was
done I was in the house when that was
added so that was I think mostly for
small towns that came in late right so I
don't think the state's going to be
likely to be in on yeah I mean that
again that that of course a16 covers all
the political subdivisions as well as
um that's like really the only other the
only other one is is uh any employer who
fails to provide within 30 days a
written request of information required
for the proper Administration that that
finds a little bigger that's that's
basically you saying I'm we're not going
to play nice with you but that's $200 a
day but again that's like it so I I with
modern computer payroll systems and all
that why would especially giant red
flags to me like what is the state not
doing that it's supposed to be doing to
Bailey this is no this is about state
agencies and then realize they've done
that in error and want to pay the town
back the state wouldn't do that though
that would be handled that it's a
retirement system is a retirement this
isn't the retirement system yeah this is
fine from the retirement system right if
they find someone in but that would be
the retirement system doing the finding
not the state yeah the state wouldn't
get involved in any right suits between
the retirement system and the town
because it says imposed on the state of
New Hampshire so this is has nothing to
do with local subdivisions at all I have
no knowledge I was just trying to
speculate how they could be
losing say what the hell is this for and
what kind of a uh
audit or um what kind of penalties fines
are you expecting to have to pay because
like yeah and what I mean we get the I I
mean I can thumb through the annual
report at some point soon to see if
there's a listing of of revenue from the
retirement system from fines but I can't
imagine it's it's not very big it can't
be big at
Allon um I I just wanted to make sure
nobody here has any idea what it would
be it doesn't seem like we would it it
looks to me as though somebody is
expecting to pay massive fines or
interest to either the retirement system
or the
IRS
and I find it difficult to
believe that what that that the state
would be screwed up on that right it's
not like this there's new special requ
requirements this year the guilty flee
where none pursueth very likely yeah I
mean the IRS will come come after you if
you file late but
uh I can't believe the state doesn't
know know when to uh when to
file they haven't changed the dates in
years this this section I was included
by the governor's
office what does she know that we don't
is the question that I've got on that
one B me there's lots of things she
knows what does she know about fines to
the
[Music]
IRS yeah that's
a either that or somebody got audited
that's I find that hard to believe
because we would I would have imagine we
would have heard this would have been
something that would have been
publicized right hell so the fact that
it's so
and the words are are carefully chosen
as well does it mean failure to report
by the retirement system is them going
hey we didn't get your numbers what's up
but IRS is a whole another animal here
letter I wonder if they're anticipating
something changing because of
Doge auditing new things the only so I
looked this up as we've been
talking um apparently so a school
district in New Hampshire did get fined
by the IRS for uh not providing health
insurance in compliance with the
ACA um that wasn't the state but I don't
know if they're anticipating something
like that but yeah I the state does
provide health insurance and I know I've
been
getting um I had the employee insurance
and they send me a note every year that
I comply with the ACA because I'm
covered with the with health insurance
so unless there's something funny like
you say that's
unanticipated they're expecting a change
right okay so I'll
go I'll go go talk with the chair
division one over over dinner or
something and and get this get these
comments because some you know some of
these
are they're mostly questions rather than
than
problems okay anybody have anything
else all right we're meeting on
Wednesday for our very last four public
hearings yay
and we will
exact
uh
um the commission on the state flag
that's 211 I think uh 525 which is the
uh DEA and heart of hearing which we
forgot to retain last last week and any
other bills that are ready
so we're actually in extremely good good
shape because after next
week we will
meet once I think to exec any bills that
we don't exec this next week so nothing
tomorrow tomorrow's Tuesday we don't do
we don't work on
Tuesdays for those that are new to Edna
this is not the normal work of this I'm
in the legislature I always do Bel
suspenders yes thank you representative
Schmid but actually after uh
uh representative Barry threatened to
fight me over whether we could meet on
Tuesdays or
Wednesdays we don't do anything on
Tuesdays my money was on
behind I have to say the setup is nice
we can actually see each other better
maybe we can go to the single rooms
although then we're going offsite next
year so yeah yes the double the double
room is not nearly as conducive to
Congeniality all right thank you all for
your
input and we'll uh that's it now there